hello how's it going today guys welcome
back to a video on code Tecna toriel's
my name is Matt your local call me
whatever you want
what are all these labels why does every
youtuber have a label I don't know
that's side rant total side rant just as
an intro it bugs me that's the side rant
I was gonna say your local computer
scientist but you know like I feel like
someone else has to give you that title
and I do have that title by the
University I graduated from but I still
don't feel like it fits me because I
have so much more to learn so uh well
this has been a bit of a humbling intro
let's just let's just get to what I was
gonna actually talk about ancient Archer
this is a game engine that I was working
on and introduced a while back and he
really just want to talk about what I'm
doing with it now it's been a while some
people have asked I did make a github
repo live without really announcing it
and yeah I just want to walk you through
my thought process my design process
what's happening with this because you
may have noticed already if you've seen
any previous videos this is nothing like
what was going on before it's very
different so I'm gonna show you
basically what I did so I'll leave a
repo link down below and I'll probably
push this branch as a restructure
because that's what's going on a giant
restructure there's as of right now
there's a master branch which is a very
old version and and it's just it has a
lot of stuff it's cluttered with a lot
of includes and libraries and stuff that
is somewhat optional if you're a game
developer because you might want to use
something else so one of the big things
I was doing well originally I was kind
of just building something to get any
kind of game done because it was for a
graphics class and that's what the
assignment basic
was and then you know and that was a big
hack job basically and I got through all
that stuff and then I really just
enjoyed working on it so I kept working
on it kept it alive kept expanding it
kept changing things kept adding things
and it was getting big and convoluted
and I was I was getting lost in my own
code so I I kept just reanalyzing things
and kept wanting to go back to the core
stuff and learn more about how I should
really be doing includes and how I
should really be thinking about
libraries and how I should be thinking
about how much memory everything's using
and stuff like that so there's just so
many different angles I have to try to
think about this engine from and on most
of them are dynamic so that's that's
what really got me stuck oddly enough is
if all this stuff is dynamic and you can
plug in whatever you want whenever you
want then why am I gonna force a user to
use this library that I chose at one
point or OpenGL rendering because that's
all I support and that doesn't really
make any sense from a gaming perspective
so I thought it would make more sense to
really work out the core loop sort of
the how the game would be designed and
leave the rendering up to the end-user
you want to use DirectX 11 12 OpenGL
Vulkan okay go ahead but yeah you know
and those all that object handling and
animation handling can be fixed in by
the proper libraries for any of those
and there's lots of open source ones so
no need for me to redesign all of them
from scratch again but and it took me a
while to to figure a lot of this out but
basically when I was in school and
learning it see here's the thing about
computer science I guess I'll go into a
little rant about what computers sign it
taking computer science courses were
like
Computers you know getting a degree in
computer science and going through all
the courses the proper curriculum the
thing I began to notice about this
particular four-year degree is they
basically teach you to build everything
from scratch there's a lot of other
degrees whether they just be like just
use this tool it's fine just use this
tool it's fine just use this tool it's
fine in computer science it's like
here's Lennox here's build this tool
here's Lennox build this tool and so you
just get used to doing everything
yourself basically and being as
unreliable or naive I didn't even
realize there were libraries for stuff
like all this stuff I was already
building but at the same time it's kind
of good because me not realizing that
there's something already done really
well made me want to build it and go
about it my own way and that's how
that's how you get good at this stuff is
you just practice you dive in you make
the best you can with what you got and
you just keep learning and you just keep
improving so that's that's like the
secret to computer science that nobody
really tells you is you just have to
dive in and do something and keep doing
something heck as an example the most
popular repo on my github is abysmal
code yeah I said it I've thought about
refactoring it for like the last year
because it seems like every couple weeks
I come up with a better system of
something I was doing before
and I see that all over the place with
my most popular repo which is DM power
it's a dungeon dragons sole command line
thing I could do that so much better now
if I took the time but the code is the
code base is so huge that there's just
no way I'm gonna set aside a week to
redesign it you know it's a total side
project I was just doing for fun but I
learned so much about handling console
input and a lot
tricks with that in just about managing
logic just by doing that program and it
wasn't that was not an assignment that
wasn't it that was just something I just
felt like doing and that on an odd way
like going through the courses in
computer science kind of got my head in
the right place about you know realizing
what I could do from the ground up but
actually doing it on my own is is what
made the difference that's important
that's really important going to school
doesn't do anything doesn't make you
anything but you actually wanting
something and making it happen you know
bringing something to fruition that
wasn't there before just by your own
ideas in your own mind that's something
special and now here's the part where
that all falls apart and that is a
everything's been done already good luck
with that
so like the problem with DM power is
it's entirely copyrighted data dungeon
dragons Dungeons & Dragons owns all that
data I just organized it to a command
line format that I liked me because I
like command line at the time and
apparently other people kind of think
it's cool too but if I were to ever like
ask for money or anything for that
program or say like you can donate here
to support the project I would get sued
by Wizards of the coast so well I don't
know they probably just cease and desist
I don't really know but it's it's a
thing I've looked into it and yeah I
literally can't make money off that
program so I guess the point is if
you're gonna be original and you want it
to be increasing your like intake
somehow there's multiple ways of doing
it you can do it completely original or
you can just have you know you can get
experience under your belt and both are
valuable because without the experience
under your belt you can't do the other
the other one of making your own
original thing so it's a tricky thing of
you just gotta do some some research and
trying things some figuring it maybe
implement systems that other people have
designed for you and things like that
that's something I'm always looking for
I'm always looking for someone that
wants to design things and it's so hard
to find someone like that because I if
you could throw me at a design and like
a layout of how things should work I can
program it that sounds really fun but if
I'm left to design and then program it
like at some point it overloads my brain
and I need to step back and rethink cuz
I'm like am i designing this right do I
need to design or program right now
designer program and sometimes I would
just get stuck in that loop I'll start
to program something and think oh I
don't want to design it like this so I
go back to design and then I think about
a little bit or maybe I lose track where
it was or so I don't know it's flopping
back and forth is not good it's not it's
not the most healthy work pattern so
it's best if you can focus and if I can
focus on design I can get it done and
that's that's typically how I get
my bigger projects done is just a lot of
focus a lot of folks and it takes a lot
of time you know you literally have to
make time for it like for example I've
found that it's nearly impossible to
program around kids because as you know
kids from noisy they're distracting they
want attention and that's awesome
but that doesn't allow your brain to go
into programmer mode it at least not for
me but I can
I can't sometimes it just depends
especially if I'm like showing if I'm
showing the code that's kind of
different or if I'm building something
like that does something you know I
guess it could be everyone's different
I'm just ranting at this point I don't
know how much of this I'm gonna leave in
the video okay so ancient Archer I've
reduced it down to a main loop and I'm
not entirely sure I'm happy with this
and the main loop is a static library so
everything else is just a demo from it
so the main loop is the crux of this
what this engine is and it's very simple
so all that other previous code I did
it's all it's all whatever it can all be
replaced but this code right here these
24 lines and a header whatever it is 24
yeah these probably won't be changed
very often if ever and they can be used
by any program at any time and all this
really does is sets you up a while loop
that allows you to interlude timing and
it's sort of designed in a way that
thinks about a
like an update and then a post update so
you have like your your main stuff going
on and then you have the display of the
results so that's basically what it does
so what you do to use it I'll show you
in console demo text okay well this is
to ask you which one you want to run
okay so let's look at an implementation
and here's a very simple one of just a
little console game that doesn't really
do anything but it's just like a sample
of what what you could do so I'm making
just a little struct here to play around
with
then I'm implementing and I'm making it
static because it's within the function
if these were declared globally outside
of the function they won't have to be
static but they're in the function they
me of your variables have to be static
and that's so you can use them and
access them and these lambdas that
you're gonna make so you're gonna get
really used to lambdas here because this
is all built around adding functions to
the loop okay so I've declared a player
or player name in an action and then I
declare my main loop and to get it we
just call a knit on the main loop
usually I do this Auto but it's a shared
pointer to it so this you can see it
explicitly what it is and I'm gonna make
a keep running Bowl because the way I
designed this main loop you got to give
it a run condition if you don't give it
a run condition it'll just exit right
away thinking about changing that a
little bit but for now one of the things
you have to do is just set a run con
that returns true or false
so all this lambda needs to do is return
true or false I'm gonna keep a keep
running variable that it's going to
return and on begin as before we go into
the mine loop the while loop the main
while loop of the engine so if we're
gonna go ahead and add this function to
it that just says well I on begin it's
like a non-user create so it's a
one-time run so we're gonna set keep
running to true and we're gonna say some
intro stuff to the whoever's playing
says welcome to a new game of trainer
enter your character's name
and it does a get line and saves the
players name so it does that once on
start and then on every update it runs
this it says enter in action and and
then it kind of tells you attack train
or quit are the valid options so it
doesn't get line on action and if you
typed quit keep running has changed
false if you typed action or if you
typed attack and your I just put some
random logic in here if your player
strength is over four you're gaining
experience and if your experience is
over strength you gain HP is just some
random logic you can put whatever you
want in there I need an enemy really to
attack or something and then if you type
train and makes your strength go up so
just some some little basic stuff to
play around with and make sure they
change and then we have a post update
this is essentially the render so after
it does all the updating and you can add
as many of these as you want and they
are added in the order that you add them
so or they are processed in the order
that you add them so when we run this
it'll just keep asking this question on
the update and it'll keep displaying the
results of course it's gonna hold at
these get lines but if we didn't have a
blocker this is will block the you know
it'll wait for you at this point the
loop will just keep going over and over
if you don't have a blocker so there we
go and I made a little demo here that's
sort of more of an AI so a sample of an
AI and I'll walk through that one next
let's run this task how my day was here
there we go set that as the one to run
hit play I'll do the text on the RPG in
there goes so we can type these in does
the trick check it that's the thing this
is really all it does just a little
sample and it'll be tight quit and
leaves but it goes back to a while loop
so the other one
does a very similar thing it in it's
this time I use Auto and we add to on
begin just a hello and then we're gonna
keep a few statics we're gonna keep it
your reply and I'm gonna keep running
bull we're doing the same thing at the
keep running bull
we just set it to true on begin that
just gives us something we can toggle
when we set the run con you basically
just do this anytime before run once you
do ml or the main loop run then it takes
off and you can't do anything else till
this returns so this actually returns a
value which is an int and that's just to
signify how it went yeah we don't really
need it for anything there and that's
why we're not saving it but the point is
once you hit run it goes through all the
stuff you set up until you quit so you
gotta have some kind of keep running set
up I've got to think about that a little
bit there's probably gonna be a better
way see the way it wasn't the old engine
in the way that was not very compatible
in the long run was I used to have it
just check if the window closed and
that's that's how that was my exit
condition was did the window closed and
that's not the best way it should shut
down the window by going through your
process cuz maybe it's got a memory that
needs to free and stuff like that you
know okay so we do we had three things
to on update we had a how was your day
and then it gets line your reply and
then it spits back out I'm good to here
you are whatever you said good luck with
that
that's all dusts and then it does
another on update and this update is
well it's just see how it's a string or
okay yeah trying to remember what I
typed it basically sees if you type the
word bad anywhere in your reply and if
you did then it says hope it gets better
soon stay strong my friend
so it just checks have you said bad
anywhere and it just says something
positive to you and if you tight
anything regarding the word quit then it
exits the program keep running as false
and of course we set the run con we
could do this earlier I usually do this
like up here but as long as you do it
before the run as long as you have those
set up before the run it's it's good and
that's that's all that one does and it's
still running in the background here let
me see there it is okay friendly robot
text chat hello how was your day and it
looks like it I need to clear an input
there because it just ran through it
I'll type good and it says stuff type
random stuff it spits it back at me if I
type the word wait and then it quits all
right
and this one's a number all right so
that's just some examples of kind of how
to use it now ideally if you're using
graphics then things will be different
you can still use this loop but you want
to involve Delta time I didn't use any
Delta time there and or Delta time comes
in well we'll just say it is supported
so let's just look at the the source
here a little bit so we're in the main
loop CPP and so once we do run it goes
through all this stuff if it's not
initialized it initializes it so you can
literally just type this main loop run
and it will it'll run the engine but it
won't do anything there's nothing set up
it'll just exit right away basically
it'll run through all this once and exit
because there's no run con
okay so runs to begin and then while
loops while checking your run con and
one in this while loop it does the
update and does the render and then at
the end it does a teardown so you can
set up stuff that needs to be dismantled
enough add to tear down okay so let's
look at this update a little closer I'm
holding some statics in the CPP of the
Delta time so in all these functions I
can use Delta time and what we can do
with that is on our update we can have a
delta update and then we can just have a
standard always updating without Delta
so every frame we can run this on Delta
update set of functions and pass it the
Delta time and that allows us to use our
Delta time and functions in design in
our own way so let me go to this console
window graphics demo say startup project
so this is using the old trick of I'll
just making a console screen and a
handle which is the console screen
buffer and set it as active this is a
Windows thing and I actually got this
from Javid X 9 well most of it I kind of
rewrote it my own way but he sets it up
in his console game engine thing and
it's basically just this here but
normally he makes a while loop so the
point of this this was was to basically
use my while loop and what he set up and
it was a great test a great way to test
the delta time and to make sure that
this could actually run something on
timing because that's what we need to
know before we go to real graphics is
can we get everything timed correctly
for more animating and stuff like that
and if we can then this is a great
little main loop to use and then we need
a test efficiency as we go and stuff
like that so it's gonna it's gonna be a
good it's gonna be a good run all right
so I said this has the startup and I
just want to walk through this real
quick so this is just a single file to
run
here and it has a main so I've got all
these declared as global so I don't need
to make them static to access them in my
lambdas later since there are outside of
the main are outside of any function but
I do have some statics for this console
screen stuff in that so I can access
them within my lambdas that I add to the
on update on the end and stuff so we got
a little map just a bunt a big string
we've got a we set up our main loop here
we just do a main lobe get which is
exactly the same as got a knit I just
made both of them because they're both
so common and they both return the main
loop so you can call get or net and then
and as you can see in this design here
there's get it just returns main loop da
done it so the in it makes sure so if
it's no and initializes it otherwise it
just returns it so we don't want to keep
realizing it in the main loop is is
within this there's only one main loop
pull out I haven't got to threading but
I guess the next step in this main loop
was to would be to allow some kind of
threading I gotta think about that some
but for now it is just single thread but
it's probably gonna be pretty easy to
implement threading if this is all kept
very clean so that's sort of the point
of this is to keep it really clean add
things very carefully and we'll go from
there okay
alright so we get the main loop I've set
the is running stuff so we set the run
con to return this in his running bull
we set it to true on the begin and then
we start adding to our updates so we got
some keys to move forward or I'm sorry
look left and right look forward or move
forward and move back you know a lot of
this oh maybe I'll link to Javits video
but he basically set up first person
controls in this console and
it's a it's an open-source thing I'll
link to it below but it's it's not I
just don't want to claim the work
because it's not mine but this is
actually I don't know if it's even
claimable because this is very
straightforward code like anyone that
uses get async key state from Windows
just included in the windows header will
do it about the same way they might have
some optimizations here and there but
this is how you do it you see if a is
pressed so you knees pressed see if W is
pressed and then process some things you
know as you can see this ad to on update
has the float DT right here so you can
name this whatever you want but this one
is overloaded to look at the Delta time
in that way you can grab it from the
engine here and run it through your
entire function so I'll show you that in
the main loop here implementation there
it is add two on update 2 on update
there's two of them
there's one that doesn't take anything
and there's one that takes a float so
when we're actually running and we're
doing this update first we do the Delta
updates and we pass it the ticks of
Delta time which is just the Delta time
and that's through the duration chrono
library and there's our just quick
little setup it's all the timing is
basically handled right within the
highlighted code right there so that's
all it takes in the library to get Delta
time throughout the entire this I guess
your entire program so it's
simplifications like this where just the
entire thing is encompassed in one spot
and make it really nice because if ever
there's ever a bug with the timing I can
just go right here and critically
analyze ten lines of code basically
rather than having to jump all over a
codebase
all right so we add it so now we have
access to this Delta time based on how
it processes this on update so we can
use it in this function and as you can
see that's where angle one returned we
use Delta time when we move forward we
use Delta time we move back we use Delta
time so that's why this this particular
update is in the Delta time one so we do
another one here this one doesn't take
Delta time because we don't need it
anywhere now this is just setting up how
thing how the screen should look before
it draws that's basically all this does
so it takes the player position into
account and how the map looks and it
sets up our map to just a giant vector W
string thing there it is
and then based on how it is we do it on
post update which is the render so after
everything's updated which check that
console screen I think we set it to null
first and then we write yeah so we blank
out the screen and then we write new
stuff over as I believe how that works
right console output character and we're
taking all the stuff we updated which is
basically these variables here not the D
word Brett bytes written that's just
there because it has to be but we take
the console screen and the handle
console in the map well just the console
screen in the handle console really
those being all updated and we just pass
it all in like like so it updates the
console so let's hit play on this and
there we go
I'm kind of seeing what you see in
Javed's video but this time I'm running
on my own loop and if I press a it goes
left and press D goes right I actually
haven't got through all the code on his
video so I haven't implemented the
coroner things he did yet I kind just
left of this because I was like all
right I see that it works good enough no
need for me to do the rest necessarily
unless I want to get more technical with
this demo I have a bug with W and s word
for some reason they like zoom you
really far I'm not sure why
I've looked and looking to decode and I
don't see what's wrong but apparently
something's wrong with these particular
functions that zoom you really far I
gotta look again anyway so it does work
as a main loop for that console window
engine known no longer need to use wild
one Javid no need your needed of course
this is additional overhead wild one is
very very cheap with this main loop does
give you some some things and in further
testing I'll find out if it's the kind
of loop I want going forward for this
engine scene and the whole point of this
is now you can plug in anything you want
into this loop this is basically your
engine you can bring your own logic you
can bring your own renderer you can
bring your own whatever you want and
this will work on this is a universal
code here there's no there's no
inclusion of Windows only on this main
loop this main loop will run on any OS
and how you want to build around it is
up to you this is just a static library
of a main loop so there you go I think
that'll do it thanks for watching thanks
for tuning in
don't forget to Like and subscribe let
me know if you like these type of videos
and let me know what you think peace out
guys